good morning everyone my name is Susan
Stokes and on behalf of bright-line
watch in the Yale program on democracy
I'm happy to welcome you to our
conference how do democracies fall apart
and could it happen here we're going to
take a couple of minutes at the
beginning in this first session to
introduce the work of bright line watch
and describe findings from recent
surveys on the performance of democracy
in the United States first I'd like to
thank a few people
Daniel stip from the William and Flora
Hewlett Foundation is somewhere here and
Joe Goldman and donatus Ogando from the
democracy fund our there's Joe and Anton
Appa and the democracy fund and Hewlett
have very generously funded the work of
bright line watch and we're very
grateful for their support
a hearty thanks also to Ian Shapiro who
I don't think he's here yet but he is
the director of the Macmillan Center at
Yale and has been very supportive of the
work this conference and the work of
bright line watch in the UH program on
democracy thanks as well to our
hard-working staff at Macmillan
thanks to Daniel Cuates who you know
from emails and now you can meet him in
person who's done just a tireless work
for this conference and for the Center
on democracy in general here at Joffrey
who may or may not be here who's also
been extremely helpful and our own
postdoctoral scholar hitmen fair heard
who I think is still helping out top but
has been very very you know terrifically
helpful in this in doing the conference
um lots of visitors from from near and
far I just wanted to a quick call out to
Elaine comm arc of the Brookings
Institution great to see you here
Rachel Kleinfeld from the Carnegie
Endowment is back there
Sarah daus cow from Cambridge University
Press great and Adriana Mendoza from the
scholars strategy Network great thank
you
one sad note I just wanted to mention
that I'll step
was scheduled to be part of this
conference and as you know I'll passed
away last week he was an incredibly
influential student scholar of democracy
how it collapses and how it keeps itself
from collapsing and we're just an
enormous ly saddened by this news but I
think we sort of feel the presence of
throughout the proceedings today so how
bright line watch got started almost
exactly this time last year I received
an email I think from Avinash Dixit of
economists from Princeton with a letter
that was being circulated among
economists that was expressing concern
about the sort of the battering that
some basic democratic institutions
related to the economy like the Fed like
the Bureau of Labor Statistics we're
taking during the campaign and also
their concerns about misinformation
about the economy that was being put
forth
I very smugly said to myself wow this is
great but you know good thing economists
but a little late right and I sent this
letter on to a number of people
including my friend and colleague
Gretchen hunky at the University of
Rochester and Gretchen immediately wrote
back and said is there a political
science letter like this so I thought
oops so much for my smugness so we
quickly wrote a letter with input from
lots of folks and within 36 hours we had
signatures from over 350 political
scientists including most passed and
then and then current president of the
American Political Science Association
and including Margaret Levy who as a
past president and who is here with us
today
so Minh either our letter nor The
Economist letter changed the course of
history and so a few weeks later after
the election we decided that it would be
important to keep the effort up and so
we founded or small organization called
bright line watch so we we got together
with colleagues John Kerry and
deny Han at Dartmouth College Mitch
Sanders who is here somewhere Mitch is
our our survey methodologist and our
name draws from a concept developed by
Barry whine gassed at Stanford
University and he's written about the
constitutional protections being a kind
of bright-line which the violation of
which should be immediately recognizable
not just to elite actors but to civil
society in general and we our work is is
in a general sense to sort of analyze
those bright lines where they are if
they exist what happens when they seem
to be violated and whether they can be
identified indeed in the current
environment in the United States we
aspire to do this by bringing our
background as students of democratic
institutions and practices not just in
the United States but internationally to
bear on the situation in the u.s. today
so in addition to this conference we've
carried out surveys of political
scientists and one of the public to
gauge their sense of what democracy is
and how American democracy is performing
and John Kerry is going to talk to us in
a minute about our survey findings
we've author also authored commissioned
and encouraged academics to write brief
essays for the public sphere bringing a
broader perspective to issues like
redistricting the integrity of elections
and impeachment so without further ado
I'm going to turn things over to John
Thanks thanks to and thank you all for
for coming this is a real thrill to have
have this group in the room so I'm going
to try to give you a very quick overview
of some of the survey results that we've
had focusing on the most recent survey
which we just published yesterday and
the some of you may have had a chance to
take a look at this I'm sure most of you
have been too busy to do so there is a
report on the bright line website you
know with much more details about these
and I'm going to try to point us to some
of the highlights I'll also note you're
receiving a statement of 27 principles
democratic principles we're violating
every rule of how to give a presentation
which is never handout a text heavy
right before you start speaking but we
did that because the core of these
bright-line surveys are batteries of
questions that revolve around these 27
statements and it would be even worse if
I were to try to show all that and text
up on the screen here so what we've done
is we've handed that out so that you
know either during my presentation or
later on you can refer to it so you kind
of get a sense for what are these
dimensions of democracy that writeline
launch is focusing on okay so what have
we tried to do this project was born out
of a concern that the trajectory of
American democracy maybe possibly in
trouble may be headed for a downturn
downturn we have tried to evaluate the
quality of American democracy both on a
wide gauge and a narrow gauge and a wide
gauge we've asked people in each of our
three surveys which took place this year
in February in May and then just last
month to evaluate the overall quality of
American democracy and in the second
survey which took place in May we also
asked our political science experts to
look retrospectively we chose dates
spanning the entire history of the
Republic and you know we asked people to
rate democracy on
point scale quality of American
democracy so what what we see when we
have that really wide gauge at least
among our experts well as a steady
increase in the quality of American
democracy peaking in the sort of mid to
late 20th century plateauing there and
then in that last iteration between 2015
and 2017 which where are the last two
dates we saw a precipitous drop-off the
first substantial drop-off and over time
so this to some degree validated our
concern that we needed to pay closer
attention the narrow gauge that we've
engaged with these 27 statements tries
to disaggregate democracy across a
number of dimensions and unfortunately
we only started this exercise in
February so if we think about the more
there's the shorter time period but the
much more finely textured evaluation
that we have what we have here are the
the question about the quality of
American democracy asks our respondents
on each of these dimensions House about
house house ustwo the u.s. doing is it
fully meeting these standards mostly
meeting these standards partly meeting
them are not meeting them at all and so
what you see here is the percentage of
our experts that said we're fully
meeting the standard or mostly meeting
it and you've got responses from
February and September there's a whole
lot of information up there but the
bottom line is that at least over these
first nine months of the Trump
administration our experts do not see
systemic degradation they see wide
variation in how we're performing across
these dimensions but they don't see
since February anyways a lot of
degradation and we're going to continue
to do this every three months and so you
know I guess what we wish is that we had
started this print this project ten
years ago and we would then have a much
more fine-grained timeline but we didn't
this will go forward with now the heart
of the bright line watch survey are two
batteries of questions around these 27
statements the first one actually asks
how important is this principle to
democracy so we'll take a look at what
we see there on this graph now again the
the respondents are presented with with
four options for each of the principles
they can either say it's absolutely
essential to democracy if you don't meet
this standard you're not a democracy
because it's very important to democracy
they can say it's beneficial nice to
have but not critical they can say it's
not relevance at all so what this graph
shows is the percentage of respondents
who said it's either essential or very
important to democracy the green dots
are our political science experts many
of you in this room the red dots are
citizens US citizens that approve of
Donald Trump and the blue dots are US
citizens who disapprove of Donald Trump
so our our our motive here was to try to
figure out first of all do our experts
view democracy anything like the general
public because one of the central
criticisms of bright line watch from the
get-go has been yeah well it's very nice
that you're asking a lot of political
scientists what they think about
democracy but we all know what political
scientists are a bunch of pointy-headed
if feet ivory tower you can add your
adjectives but their opinions have
nothing to do with those of the general
public all the things we see is actually
our opinions do have something to do
with those of the general public but the
patterns are not dramatically different
here and the other thing about this
graph that I think is important is that
the patterns across Trump approvers in
Trump disapprove as Trump opponents are
not dramatically different they differ
on some critical items they differ on
their the importance that they have
signed to equality of legal and
political rights equality of voting
rights and some other essential elements
of electoral fairness like whether
districts should be biased whether there
should be whether foreign influence on
Elections as a critical violation of
democracy but on the whole what we take
away from this graph is that democratic
values are not all that different across
these Cruz
the second main battery in the
bright-line watch surveys are on the
same 27 statements how do you think
we're doing how do you rate current
Democratic performance in the United
States and here we see much more
polarization across groups between
especially between Trump supporters and
Trump opponents but we also see that
when we ask our experts on more items
than not the experts actually rate
American democracy as performing better
than the general public and in many
cases better than both of approvers in
disapproves of Donald Trump this is kind
of surprising to us it's not true for
every item and of course you can see
these these items are ranked according
to the performance evaluation of the
experts so the top of the scale the
experts are substantially more sanguine
about the performance of US democracy
than the public at the bottom of the
scale they swing expert opinion tends to
be more polarized than than public
opinion on this again in the interest of
time I'm going to move very quickly all
of these graphs are available in our
report and I also want to emphasize
especially well to everybody in the room
all of our data are available on the
website already we we have not even had
time yet to do 1/10 of the analysis that
we look forward to doing on these but we
one of the things we're committed to at
bright-line watch is making everything
publicly available immediately and so if
you want to download these and play with
them yourselves we encourage you to do
so the last two slides I'll show you are
moving to again taking a step back from
that disaggregated 27 dimensions of
democracy to to questions that we asked
in this most recent survey both of the
experts and of the general public one of
them is how important is it to you to
live in a democracy again what we've
done here is just superimpose the expert
opinion in green
over the public opinion in purple the
experts are slightly more committed to
the to the idea of democratic government
but both both groups remain
overwhelmingly committed to the
principle of living in a democracy and
finally this also kind of makes even
more stark the difference between expert
and public opinion on performance here
we have the experts in green this was
reading the quality of US democracy on a
100-point scale we've been the responses
in 2d silence now what you see is that
the experts on the whole I think was the
was the median response 80 to 100 I
think 72 sorry 72 out of 100 so we all
get it we get about a c-minus according
to the experts well actually a Dartmouth
I guess that would be the public is
substantially lower and I think the
public is around 59 and I'm looking for
support over here because I can't
remember but whether we look at the
narrow gauge or whether we look at the
broad gauge the experts appear to be a
bit more optimistic and we speculate a
little bit about this that we think part
of this may be because so many of our
experts have broader comparative
experience and one of the things we did
with this conference was trying to bring
comparative scholarly experience into
the room many of us have spent a good
deal of our lives studying places where
democracy has eroded sometimes
dramatically and I think the experts may
with that broader comparative expect
perspectives still see us democracy more
optimistically than the public does so
I'll finish up just by saying you know
we founded this project as sue mentioned
to try to figure out are there bright
lines in American democracy if so what
are they our 27 statements are our first
effort to try to zero in on some places
that we think bright lines could
potentially exist but we want to try to
use our surveys and and our other
efforts to try to figure out how would
know when or whether we're crossing
whether we're crossing lines that
threaten democracy and how would we know
when we might be approaching a
transgression of those lines that would
prompt a response and defense of
democracy we've drafted our surveys
trying to focus attention on that the
responses are new we're processing the
information ourselves we really are
still in the process of doing that we're
formulating our reactions but part of
what we're asking you to do at this
conference is to help us with that
process and so I really look forward to
hearing everybody else's comments over
the course of day thank you
[Applause]
mm sorry it's late technical difficulty
think about what jokes you want to tell
yourselves when you get depressed by the
end of the day
so I'll get started and we'll have
slides that we'll catch up soon so my
name is Joe Goldman I'm the president of
the democracy fund which is a bipartisan
foundation in Washington DC created by
the founder of eBay we along with our
colleagues Madison initiative and the
Hewlett Foundation are really happy to
be able to support this important work
today so I wanted to say a couple words
about slides that have not shown up yet
I wanted to say a couple words about why
it was important for us to support this
work and then wanted to talk a little
bit about a parallel piece of research
that we have supported that we hope will
be complementary to this work there we
go so just again so the foundation that
I run we've been around for a few years
now we have programs supporting kind of
bipartisan efforts to make elections
work better we have a program that works
with Congress to see in this polarized
time what are things that can be done to
make Congress work a little bit better
we do a lot of work with journalism and
finding ways for to make sure the
American public gets the information
that they need to be better informed and
engaged in society coming out of this
election we found ourselves feeling that
like there were really two important
things that that we really needed to do
that were different than what we had
done before the first was to really get
focused on what are the things that the
nonprofit and reform community can do to
ensure that the basic institutions of
checks and balances within our system
are functioning as well as possible and
so for us that has meant making major
investments in journalism whether that
is directly supporting nonprofit
newsrooms we made a 10 million dollar
commitment to a series of nonprofit
newsrooms we have supported
litigation an advocacy support for
journalists it means trying to bolster
checks and balances within the executive
branch the legislative branch and the
courts whether that means protecting
whistleblowers whether it means helping
staff in Congress who have not don't
have a lot of experience performing
oversight figuring out how to play that
role and it means actually going to
court when necessary to defend important
rights that might be infringed upon and
this work has meant kind of standing up
for those communities that may be
threatened in these times especially the
American Muslim community but it's also
been really important for us to both
draw a bright line on what is abnormal
in these times but also to try to really
understand more about why why we find
ourselves in this position and what's
going on and to that end we created this
thing called the voters study group and
the idea behind the voter study group
was to bring together a group of
analysts and scholars from across the
political spectrum and that means on the
Left we have folks from the Center for
American Progress from Brookings from
New America on the right it means we
have folks from heritage action from
Cato from AE I in the middle Q Research
Center Latino decisions many others and
the notion is get this folk get this
group of folks in a room to agree not
not to agree on everything about what's
going on but to agree that we're gonna
study what's going on together and be in
conversation together and part of the
reason we want to do this is to inform
each other and and kind of get ourselves
out of each other's bubbles but also
when we want to when we put out analyses
of what's going on we want to make sure
wherever you sit on the political
spectrum you can see someone from this
group who has credibility with you right
because part of what we're concerned
with is kind of political and policy
elites creating interpretation about
interpretations about what's going on
that are not kind of grounded in data
and accurate and we want to try to fix
that right so we actually ran a first
survey back in December two things that
were really interesting about the survey
right one is we had a very large end
right so we had we interviewed 8,000
people which means we have a lot of
statistical power and the second thing
is this was a longitudinal study so we
re interviewed people who had been
interviewed in 2011 and 12 in 2016
during the primaries then after the
general so we actually have data about
how opinions have changed over time not
just kind of projections about how
opinions have changed over time so we
put out a first set of reports in the
spring from this data a couple kind of
interesting things we're jumping out
right one because of the unique nature
of the data we had we could actually
look at how people's votes had changed
you know who were they kind of party
switchers right and on one level you
know what you see up here is that people
remained pretty consistent in their
party voting right people who voted for
Mitt Romney tended to vote for Donald
Trump people who voted for Barack Obama
tended to vote for Hillary Clinton but
it wasn't totally the case and in fact
more Barack Obama voters supported
Donald Trump than Mitt Romney voters
supporting Hillary Clinton and digging
into kind of who these party switchers
are is super interesting and kind of all
the data on this is up on the web at
voter study group I'd highly recommend
taking a look at it this this graph is
from a report by John John sighs what we
were also able to do was kind of dig
into the party coalition's and Emilee
Eakins a Cato wrote a report where she
essentially created a typology of Trump
and kind of this is the the five
categories that that she created and no
token this is kind of how she defined
these folks and these party switchers on
these folks who voted for Barack Obama
and then ended up voting for Donald
Trump kind of fall in this American
preservationist category right folks
lower education levels lower economic
prospects deeply kind of
anti-establishment and kind of super
interesting to understand right so we
put a second study into the field this
summer where we interviewed 5,000 folks
from the same longitudinal panel and
this time we included a battery of
questions about kind of support for
democracy and you know I think this data
ends up being pretty complementary to a
lot of the kinds of things that we're
learning from bright lines right so we
asked for kinds of questions about 12
questions in all within this battery of
a larger survey a set of questions about
kind of what are your attitudes about
different kinds of political system
whether it's a democracy army rule a
strong leader who doesn't have to deal
with checks and balances we asked about
kind of satisfaction with democracy and
and and what you think about how this
political system is working in the US
and then we asked a series of questions
about kind of how you think about checks
and balances as well as kind of
toleration towards others and you know
one thing I would just point out is I
think often we get we start focusing on
questions about satisfaction with
Washington with democracy in a way that
doesn't distinguish between how we feel
about democracy versus an alternative
right and we think the more important
and interesting question is how many
folks are actually supportive or
considering an alternative to a
democracy not just am i dissatisfied and
when we get into the data we actually
find these are very different groups of
people those who are dissatisfied with
what's going on here a lot that covers a
wide range of different perspectives
that's very different than
those who are open to a strong leader
who doesn't have to deal with checks and
balances or army rule so here's just a
quick kind of high-level data on this
question of strong leader army rule and
then a democracy now good news right a
lot of people think democracy is a good
thing but we do see you know 18 percent
think it's a either a fairly good or a
very good idea to have army rule 24
percent say that about a strong leader
and if anything these numbers are low
because the nature of our sample means
we have a lower percentage of non-voters
and when we look at the data we see that
non voters have much a much higher
likelihood of supporting these kind of
alternatives but this kind of surface
light so there are a couple ways you can
go with this data right one is to try to
understand is this changing and some of
the folks who will be speaking today
have really looked at that's quite a bit
the other direction you can go is to try
to understand who are these people
and I think that the nature of our data
set allows us to try to to look into
these questions and I've been working
with Larry diamond at Stanford and lead
ruttman at new America to get it get in
at these questions we'll have a paper
out next month digging into this but I
wanted to share a couple data points
right so so one is so yes we see some
differences between Clinton and Trump
voters that's not surprising this was a
question about kind of how you think
about oversight over the executive
branch not surprising that Trump voters
might specifically be more supportive of
a stronger executive when they're there
guys in office but we can also dig into
primary support right because we have
longitudinal data we can see how do
Kasich voters differ from Trump voters
and we actually see a pretty big
distinction between a Kasich voter and a
Trump voter here right and then if we go
back to that that earlier framework from
Emily Eakins when we think about the
different kind different groupings
within the Trump electorate we actually
see some pretty significant distinctions
right the American preservationist group
turns out they're actually much more
open to alternatives to democracy
and then some of the others the free
marketeers and and the staunch
conservatives so important to kind of
understand and think about right and
then you know we we go kind of deeper
and we looked for what are other
characteristics of these folks who are
open to democratic alternatives
education ends up being an important
perspective news consumption ends up
being a portent perspective satisfaction
satisfaction with democracy a sense of
community this disorder ends up being
important anti elite attitudes whether
or not you are a voter or not these are
all things that end up being
interestingly correlated with support
for democratic alternatives and and what
we're really trying to dig into and
understand is kind of to try to pull
these things apart one of the things one
of the things we find right is there's a
limit to how far you can actually go
with quantitative data you can only find
so much out from a survey and I think
one of the things we think is important
is is to be able to pair this work with
qualitative research to really dig into
who these folks are and what is driving
their attitudes so just to close with a
with a with a couple quick points right
so one is just to reiterate we think
it's really important to try to dis a
great and and figure out what is the
difference between those who are
dissatisfied with our democracy versus
those that are open to alternatives
second for those of us who want to then
do something about it it becomes really
interesting to think about the
difference between those who are at the
extremes right those who think army rule
or a strong leader is a very good idea
versus those who are kind of maybe right
because kind of as though as folks
wanting to do something about it you
need to figure out which of those camps
is the more concerning and which you
which you really want to focus on I
think it's a really important question
again we think qualitative data is going
to be really important to dig into this
stuff and then finally you know at so as
someone who works with a lot of folks
who work on press freedom who work
government oversight being able to kind
of disaggregate this kind of data and
understand who are the subpopulations
that within a broader elected electorate
that are open to these things becomes
really important and useful to kind of
the Reformers and and other actors who
are trying to work on these things
because as you're trying to work on
messaging as you're trying to work on
campaigns to influence folks on these
things being able to figure out who you
need to sub target becomes really really
important and interesting so there's a
lot more data and we'll have a lot more
to say about a month from now this was
just kind of a quick preview of some of
the things that Larry Lee and I have
been digging into from the voter study
group data all of the the raw data from
the original survey is up online at
voter Citigroup org but anyway really
glad to be here hope I'm not too
depressed by the end of the day and look
forward to digging in the conversation
[Music]
already but we're gonna just take a
couple of questions and then switch
without it without anybody moving from
their seats for the next panel so just
maybe two questions
and who's coming from the 50s and 60s
and 70s it showed a very significant
sort of lack of support for some poor
fundamental values are you looking at
some of this we have not started to do
that yet but but yeah I think that's
little it's a good item to add to our
agenda you know and the one thing I'd
said and my academic my academic
colleagues can speak better to this than
I but how you weren't a given question
on these things ends up being really
really important and I think one of the
challenges certainly that we've run up
against is kind of consistency of the
questions that are being asked and so
how to how to compare across time but
super init super important
[Music]
I'll address it yeah you right actually
few if you look at the list of 27 most
of them do focus on institutions
governing elections checks and balances
formal accountability procedures there
are but but you're also right that if I
think about the discussion and the
preoccupation about Trump in particular
both during the campaign and the
presidency so much of the discussion has
been about norms of civility discourse
and so forth we do have three items
maybe four that do where we do our best
to try to focus on that and if you see
there at the bottom of the list not not
because we regard them as the least
important but you know that was a
idiosyncrasy of the list and a couple of
items to note about that if you remember
you know this sort of importance and
performance batteries that we asked
about on both importance and performance
those items ranked low in people's
estimation and we were a little
surprised by that I was a little
surprised by that actually and I think
that's an area where I wonder we're kind
of working through what does that mean
in the survey I think there's pretty
widespread acknowledgement both in the
public and by our experts that those are
the areas where you know our
expectations about American democracy
have been degraded the most in the last
couple of years maybe maybe even further
but it's also to me surprising that
people have rated those as among the
least important items so we're not
ignoring that area but we didn't you
know it was easier for us maybe this
reflects a
so these are for us to sort of tick off
a number of institutional
characteristics of democracy than it was
to come up with normative ones and and
this is an area where we would invite
feedback and phosphate are there are
there other principles are there other
statements that we should be including
that reflect norms of civility discourse
and behavior that we're not including
[Applause]
[Music]